-Due to the
coronavirus outbreak,
many events that people look
forward to every year
have been postponed or
called off completely.
Yesterday, towns across
the country
were forced to cancel
their Easter parades.
Well, we here at "Late Night
couldn't stand by
and let that happen,
so here is one of my writers
Amber Ruffin,
with the world's first
quarantine Easter parade.
-Hello. I'm Amber Ruffin,
and I'm wearing a gown
because I feel like it.
Now, I love parades.
And I don't think we shoul
all have to miss out
on the fun of Easter parades
just because
we're all locked up
in our houses.
So I'm throwing an
Easter quarantine parade
for you, right now,
from my house.
♪♪♪♪
Oh! And here comes
the first float.
Let's take a look.
Our first float in the Easte
quarantine parade is, of course,
the alcohols of quarantine
Oh, I see there's vodka,
everyone's favorite,
and his best friend, tequila
Not my favorite brand, but i
was on sale, so I got two.
And triple sec.
You can't have a margarita
without triple sec --
that is, until all your
triple sec runs out.
Then you can...and will!
Now, those are all, of course,
evening drinks.
During the day, it's Moscato
Ah! And here comes
the second float
in the Easter quarantine parade,
jeans and bras!
Now, fun fact about
these jeans --
I haven't worn them
for over 27 days
and I don't know
if I ever will again.
And speaking of things I'l
never wear again, bras.
By the way, today's parade i
sponsored by margaritas.
Margaritas, thank you.
I love you.
Up next, oh,
it's the tangerines!
A very personal
Easter quarantine float
for me, because once
every two weeks,
my husband buys a giant ba
of tangerines.
Now, we have a mix of
fresh ones and old ones.
Fun fact -- I've never seen my
husband eat a tangerine.
He buys them, brings them home
and never throws them away
Let's hear it for tangerines
Oh, we've got
a beautiful crowd out there.
Let's take a look.
Now, we've got
a big, shiny bulldog,
Mommy and Daddy,
and some lucky cats.
Mommy and Daddy -- the onl
things keeping the peace
between the bulldog
and the cats.
Good job, Mommy and Daddy.
Next up, books!
That's right --
that big, fat pile of book
you planned on reading durin
the quarantine
is still there waiting
for you to crack
at least one of them open.
Sorry, books.
I guess you'll have to wai
for the next pandemic.
Next up, a favorite of
the Easter quarantine parade
It's a dozen chocolate-chi
cookies!
Now, these cookies -- Wait
Where are these cookies?
Oh, that's right.
They were eaten seconds afte
coming out of the oven
instead of dinner because we'r
more animal than human now
Kind of funny anyone
actually thought
that they would survive
until the next day.
And, of course,
the final float in
the Easter quarantine parade
a Zoom meeting!
That's right -- your
least-favorite colleagues
all on one screen!
Now, that's it for the
quarantine Easter parade.
I'd like to thank everyone who
made the time to come out today,
especially Mommy and Daddy
I'd also like to thank our
sponsor, margaritas.
Margaritas --
if it weren't for them,
I would have murdered my husband
by now, with a tangerine.
That's it for us.
Back you to, Seth.
-Thank you to Amber Ruffin
We'll be right back.